and i want to share with you a young man
who grew up in the hood
in the midst of gangs
in the midst of turmoil in the midst of
difficulty but was able to escape all of
that
[Music]
i'm still here that's right 100 days in
a tent on the south side of chicago
that's where i'm making my home right
back there
thank you for being with us on our
rooftop revelations night after night
day after day thanks to fox for giving
me this platform and tonight i want to
jump right in and i want to share with
you a young man who grew up in the hood
in the midst of gangs
in the midst of turmoil in the midst of
difficulty but was able to escape all of
that
and
do something with his life
that we're trying to get a lot of young
black brothers to do
so i want to welcome tonight tm richards
uh here to the rooftop where we're
having this
rooftop revelation and i want to jump
right in here's the question all right
how did you end up learning
to be a pipe fiddle because
you from the hood man you from you from
you you deep in the hood too you ain't
just you from the hood of hoods yeah and
you but you're a pipe fitter you're
making good money taking care of
yourself how did that happen uh my it
was it was kind of forced upon me yeah
my uh my pop i grew up in the trades and
so
he was teaching me you know how to work
on boilers and furnaces but uh he kind
of
took me and made me go down there and
sign up so your dad
made you go down and sign up to be a
pipeline correct
man
let me ask you a question
some of your friends
who didn't have dads in their life
to to make them get up and go learn to
trade you know
what where are they what are they doing
what's going on with them
it's unfortunate but a lot of them uh
you know deceased or in jail
so it's a lot of guys
deceased and in jail
because they didn't get the proper
guidance they went the right direction
that's what we're trying to predict
that's reason why we're trying to build
this center
because i really do believe in my heart
that even in the absence of fathers i
promote fathers being in their child's
life
but we all know that that's not going to
happen in a lot of cases it's just
outside
but we got to build
institutions that come alongside these
single mothers
and give these young brothers
maybe a trade
and they can be just like you
working hard you know one of the things
i love about you is that you work hard
nobody has to tell you get up no you're
not you're not lazy is what i'm saying
you're not dependent on government
you're not depending on me you're not
depending on anybody else to do it you
you actually get out there and hustle
and do it thank you i appreciate it
you think
last question i want to ask you
do you think we could be successful if
we give other young men these
opportunities
uh definitely
i definitely do i think uh
i think it was it has been you know a
lot of uh
i just had a lot of resources that i've
seen you know that have come through you
you know what i mean i've been watching
throughout the years you know i've i've
been around this church for a decade or
more and
i've just witnessed you know like uh
well my buddy rafa built this and it's
it's amazing you know what i mean some
of these things that you know
who would think that a porch could be
built on top of connie i have a 40-foot
context box myself over there where i
stay and who would have thought that
that a porch you know or a deck
structure could be built you know on top
of a conex box so i definitely think you
know it would be advantageous for us to
uh
pour young young men in the trades
definitely
that's what we're gonna do that's the
reason why we got project good we're
gonna continue to build it and help as
many brothers as we possibly can
so we can have a lot more teams
uh with trades a lot more users making
money
and taking care of the community that's
what it's all about i love you guys
appreciate it
thank y'all for being with us on rooftop
revelations that's what it's all about
this is how we change lives get people
in trades get people a job give them a
work ethic help them to become
everything that they can be that's
reason why we need y'all so bad we
really do i need you to help me wherever
you are in the country wherever you are
in the world thanks and shout out to fox
for giving us this platform and uh we
really need help we need to build this
so i'll see you later uh on tomorrow but
until then peace
you